what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the newest
major twist in boku no hero although
let's face it we all knew that this was
coming we just didn't know when
exactly it would happen there were
actually two major developments in this
latest installment of the story
one was about deku and his power and the
other one was about shigaraki
and his power yet again the situation on
the battlefield has shifted and things
just keep getting more and more intense
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
boku no hero content and you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really does help
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
if you want to actually see our videos
and not have them buried on youtube you
have to go through the trouble of
clicking that bell and selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a lot of our videos even if you
are subscribed it's just how youtube
works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers we are dealing with the very
latest developments in the story so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the end of the
previous chapter gave us a preview of
the
absolute chaos that gigantomachia had
caused back in the forest
near the villain mansion but the latest
chapter gives us a much closer look at
the carnage and the aftermath
of that carnage the class 1a and 1b
students appear to be ok
at least the ones that we get to see but
the path that machia had taken through
the forest has been reduced to an
absolute wasteland machia has
annihilated the trees
the ground and everything else in his
path
and even though some of the students
like tokoyami are working on rescuing as
many people
as possible it wouldn't be crazy to
assume that some heroes might have died
during makia's rampage sero asks
shoji if there are any other heroes in
the area but shoji can't sense
any of them which means that all the
heroes who are still around
are too far away to detect so does that
mean that all those heroes who had been
here are now dead
or maybe they're just unconscious we'll
have to wait and see
momo and the rest of the students are
absolutely shocked
by what they just witnessed and they
know that the only reason they survived
is because makia wasn't
interested in them he was just looking
for the quickest way to reach jakku
and once he underwent his transformation
the transformation that we got to see a
preview of
in the last chapter machia destroyed
everything and everyone
in sight i have to say that makia is
even more powerful than i could have
possibly imagined and his new form looks
absolutely insane thankfully majestic
was able to save all the students by
using his unique quirk to fly them
out of makia's path and since makia
wasn't
interested in the students only in
reaching shigaraki he didn't pursue them
and so they survived but once the
students were evacuated into the forest
and out of makia's way
things did not work out so well for the
heroes machia seems to have just
plowed through them leaving nothing but
destruction
in his wake the students are left
wondering what happened to the pro
heroes like fat gum
and majestic and also to the other
students like sun eater
and they are also left wondering why
momo's sleeping agent did not have an
effect
on machia but the chapter doesn't dwell
on the shock and confusion of the
students for very long
because we are suddenly thrust back into
the scene from the end of the previous
chapter
and we can see that the newly
transformed machia is already causing
massive
large-scale destruction inside a city
all the efforts of the heroes and hero
students back at the mansion
appear to have been worthless since they
couldn't stop machia
and now he is annihilating entire cities
he is killing who knows how many
innocent civilians
and he is getting closer and closer to
shigaraki on top of that
or should i say on top of machia the
other villains including dabi toga
spinner mr compressed and skeptic
are also about to join the battle in
jakku now that
both shoto and endeavour are on the main
battlefield in jakku
dabi's appearance there is going to be
absolutely epic
i can't wait to see what happens also we
hadn't seen dr
ujiko for a while but now we see him
again and he is being taken into custody
by the authorities
despite his current predicament ujjiko
is ecstatic to learn that machia
is on his way and ujico explains that
machia is a calamity
in human form and a creature who lives
and dies
for his master in fact ujico based his
nomu designs
on machia himself so machia
is the literal prototype for the perfect
villain
soldier ujico proclaims that once machia
gets going there is no way to stop the
destruction
and with makia's help shigaraki is about
to end the hero society
once and for all back on the main
battlefield in jakku
we see a fully recovered shigaraki
rising from the ashes
as a badly injured isawa lies motionless
on the ground
there is a large amount of blood around
isil's eyes as we saw in the previous
chapter
and we cannot actually see his eyes at
this point
so i'm not sure if isaw's eyes were
actually injured beyond repair
or if the blood is coming from some
other injury
but that doesn't seem to actually matter
at this point because izawa
is clearly no longer capable of
performing the task of erasing
shigaraki's quirks
shoto offers to help out with shigaraki
so that endeavor can take some time to
cool off and replenish his strength
meanwhile both deku and bakugo are
furious as they look upon the
injured izawa but the situation is so
bad that
rock clock straight up tells deku to get
out of here
raw clock and manual are both doing
their best to take care of izawa
but izawa is in really bad shape and
with shigaraki fully recovered
everyone here is in grave danger deku
bakugo and shoto
are still just students so it makes
sense for the heroes to give them a
chance to flee
in this dire and dangerous moment so
being the reasonable and pragmatic guy
that he is
deku does exactly what rock clock tells
him to do
and so he gets the hell out of there and
that's it the chapter ends
nothing more to see just kidding of
course deku doesn't listen to rocklock's
advice
instead rage mode deku with tears
flowing down his face and pure
fury in his eyes declares that he will
never leave
and in that moment something crazy
happens
as shigaraki prepares to launch another
wave of decay
a large gash suddenly opens across his
chest
and right arm shigeruki has no idea
what's going on first
but then he realizes that by pulling
ayami from black clover and surpassing
his limits
he has put too great a strain on his
body but
even so shigaraki is surprised that he
isn't regenerating instantly
and that's when he realizes that he must
have been awakened
too early before ujjiko's procedure
could be completed deku is also able to
connect the dots based on what gran
torino had said earlier
and so deku knows that the overwhelming
power of all for one
is putting a big strain on shigaraki's
body
thanks to mirko's heroic sacrifice
shigaraki's procedure was interrupted
when it was only about
75 percent completed and the chapter
then briefly shows us that the gravely
injured miracle
is still alive and that she is being
carried off to safety
as we speak man i love my girl miroko
and so i'm glad that we actually got
proof of life in this chapter
because we weren't so sure about what
happened to her after she was carried
out of the hospital by endeavour
stay strong miroko we simp for you and
we're proud of it
back on the battlefield shigaraki's
super regeneration kicks in again
and he once again attempts to launch a
massive wave of decay
but before the decay can reach the
heroes deku uses black whip to grab all
of them
and to elevate them off the ground as
deku jumps into the air he appears to
stay up there
floating and this allows him to keep the
other heroes
airborne as well it is then revealed
that our boy gran torino
despite being severely injured is in
fact
still alive at least for now gran torino
who was beaten within an inch of his
life just a couple of chapters ago
realizes what is happening dekku has
just unlocked
nana float and he is now using it to
protect himself
and his friends and fellow heroes from
shigaraki's decay
the chapter ends as deku lunges at
shigaraki
his fist ready to go and deku declares
that they are
ending this right here and now wow
what crazy hype and what a major
momentum
shift we've already seen this happen
multiple times during this
arc but just when it seems like the
villains are unstoppable something
happens to even the odds once again
with machia on his way izawa down for
the count
and shigaraki fully recovered and able
to use all of his quirks
it looked like the heroes were pretty
much done for they didn't stand a chance
but then within a matter of moments deku
unlocks nana's quirk
and shigaraki is revealed to have a
major weakness
float is of course the perfect quirk for
avoiding the spread of shigaraki's decay
and the fact that shiraki's procedure
was only 75
completed means that his body is still
unstable
and so despite his immense power he may
be vulnerable
after all horikoshi has really made this
arc an absolute rollercoaster ride and i
am here for it
we all knew that deku was going to
unlock float sometime soon
it was directly foreshadowed multiple
times but i have to say that the way in
which deck unlocked it and the precise
moment in which he unlocked it was
pretty freaking
epic he was able to save all the major
players on the battlefield
and himself while also putting shigaraki
back on the defense
the ability to float and to make others
float will presumably eliminate the
threat of shigaraki's decay
for the major players on the battlefield
at least for the time being
but we can't forget that shigaki still
has a ton of other quirks
so deku unlocking the ability to float
will not necessarily
end the battle on its own the other big
and i mean
big problem that the heroes are facing
is of course gigantomachia who is on his
way to the battlefield with a whole
bunch of other powerful villains
now it is totally possible that the
sleeping agent will begin to have an
effect on machia
after some time passes so that might
slow him down or even stop him
completely
nevertheless the sleeping agent
obviously won't have an effect on dobby
toga and the other villains who are
hitching a ride on top of makia so as
long as makia can get close to shigaraki
shigaraki will still get reinforcements
even if machia himself
ends up passing out from the sleeping
agent at some point down the line
oh man i honestly don't know what to say
i'm excited by so much stuff that just
happened
what an action-packed chapter miroko
is alive gran torino is alive at least
for now
deku unlocks a new quirk shigaraki's
body is breaking down
makia is on his way dobby is about to
come face to face with endeavour and
shoto
so much happening all at once please let
me know what you guys thought of this
chapter do you agree with me that it was
absolutely
awesome and what do you expect is going
to happen next
is deku going to be able to take
shigaraki down using his new quirk
or is shigaraki going to bounce back
despite his body breaking
down are gran torino and miracle going
to pull
through are we finally going to get the
dobby identity reveal
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more boku
no hero content on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alone
adam the world
acquired respect pate heffa jonathan
king
brandon aviles papa smurf emperor otaku
thomas jones kid mano
and admirath finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica califond hinokai and water
bonnie parks ratheora florian
joni garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you